All right. Hello everyone. So, we're
here. It's May 15th. We're at the second
session on chapter two on Sanjeev's new
textbook Fundamentals of Active
Inference.
And uh we're going to be we're going to
be finishing chapter two in this session
and uh sort of setting up chapter three
and going through any questions there
uh that we've had so far.
So, I think I'll just uh begin sharing
my screen here.
There we go.
Just that single window would be nice.
All right. So, maybe uh just before we
get stuck into the example where we left
off, um
what we're doing in chapter two, so I'm
in the chapter two code right here.
Uh we're looking at how the inverse
problem in chapter one becomes something
practical and computational that we can
actually do.
Uh so, you know, we saw in chapter one
what is the the question is what is
perception. And we framed it in terms of
hidden state inference. And then this
chapter is really about how do we do
that? You know, how do we actually get
our hands dirty and do hidden state
inference? So, action is is later. We're
not doing active inference just yet.
We're having we're getting our feet wet
with respect to the question about how
we infer really anything at all. And the
thing that we're inferring is uh is a
hidden state of the environment. So,
we only have Hang on. I'll just view
this.
Okay. Let people in. We only have um
one thing that we're inferring, which is
the hidden state of this very very
trivial example that we're looking at.
Uh we have, you know, hidden food size
and we have light intensity. We observe
the light intensity.
So, all of the examples are different
kind of flavors of that same example in
this in this chapter. So, that's kind of
where we left off. And we specifically
left off, I think it was um
example 2.4,
which and the corresponding figure for
that is 2.16. Is that right? No, example
2.6 and the corresponding figure is
2.16.
So,
where we were is and then we're going to
move so we we we covered sections 2.1
and 2.2 last time, which effectively are
the first half of the chapter.
Uh and that's
I would say the core of the material
that we're going to see some interesting
ideas later on towards the end.
This This particular example we I I I
did mention it last time, but I I we
sort of rushed through it a bit.
We're looking at the effects of two
different modeling assu- well,
an incorrect modeling assumption here.
So, we have our generative process.
There's some food sizes that generating
light intensities.
That's the real world and then we have
our model in which we make assumptions
about what the relationship is between
hidden food sizes and light intensities,
okay?
Uh and one one crucial thing
that it's worthwhile to highlight about
this chapter is that
our model has these things called
parameters. They are like settings of
the various dials in our assumptions
about what the relationship is between
the the food size and the light
intensity. So,
and the the crucial thing is that those
parameters are they have just been given
to us, you know, from upon high. They
are they're they're assumed to be
good parameters, good setting of the
parameters from the get-go.
So, we're going to have to check two
here.
Uh
we have two points.
Why is it here? So, there we go. Well,
this is the environment 2.14.
Can I zoom in?
Slightly. So, this is kind of the
probabilistic representation of that
what our model is in chapter two.
And what we're saying is, okay, the
relationship between the hidden states
and the light intensity is given by this
equation here. It's a linear equation.
Um and these these these numbers beta
zero and beta one, those are called
parameters. They are kind of knobs that
we can turn, dials that we can set that
specify the particular relationship
about how hidden states give rise to
observations. So for us, we have just
been told from upon high, look, you
know, beta zero is three and beta one is
two. Okay? What we're going to see later
on in chapter three is that the there is
an additional problem usually when we're
doing hidden state inference, which is
that yes, we want to do hidden state
inference, but we actually don't know
what these parameters should be. We need
to first learn what the parameters
should be of our of our model and then
do hidden state inference with them. Or
indeed, we can we can combine those
processes.
But for us at the moment, we're assuming
that they're they're given. Okay? So
that's an important asterisk. It's an
important layer of complexity that we're
actually sort of hiding from you right
now
uh
for didactic purposes.
Go back here.
Now, okay, so
the parameters in our model for example
2.6, they they happen to match, I
believe they do, they happen to match
the generative process.
Okay, so they're both, you know, beta
zero in the well, beta zero star, the
thing belonging to the generative
process is three, beta one star is two.
That's the same in our model, but
crucially, in our model, we uh
Oh, sorry, in in the process,
the actual relationship between the real
hidden state and the real latent
intensity is given by a non-linear
transformation. Okay? I'll I'll show you
I'll show you what that is. This is
equation 2.18.
But in our model, we're assuming that
the the relationship is linear. So our
our model is incorrect. The the real
state of the world is not at all what we
think it is. Okay?
So let's see if we can just quickly go
back cuz it is important to to look at
that. So 2.18,
uh Uh,
or rather 2.16. So, this is the
Is that correct? It's 2.16. I have it up
here.
No, we want 2.18. That's what we want.
Okay.
Do you bear with me? So, here's the This
is the real generative process. Okay,
this is the equation I was just talking
about. Hopefully, this is zoomed in
enough to I I was looking back at the
recording my recording from last Friday
and some of the equation and the and
figures I I did show were quite we were
a bit small. So, if you're having
trouble, uh, you know, reading things as
I'm sharing them,
uh, do do raise your hand or anything
like that.
Okay, so this is the real state of the
world in in example 2.6. We see that
Look, this is the actual relationship
that obtains between the hidden states
and the the observations.
So, G sub E is a function that gives us
R,
our observation. And what is it defined
by? It's defined by this, beta zero plus
beta one plus phi. This this
weird-looking thing is phi of X star.
What is that? What is phi of X star?
It's just another name for X star
squared, so X times itself. This is
non-linear. So, anytime you're
multiplying something by itself, that is
not a linear transformation. This is
this is like a a
parabola or a curve here.
That's the real state of the
environment, but the model 2.19 does not
assume this. So, if I go to here,
we see in the model, this is exactly the
same to the uh, the real generative
process, but we're still assuming that
the observation generating process is
linear. Okay, so our model's incorrect.
It's not right. It's not correct in this
in this example.
So, uh, we're going to see 2. Uh,
figure 2.16 shows you the consequence of
this modeling assumption.
So, this is a little bit confusing
because in in the prior examples and
panels in this chapter, what you've been
seeing is you've been seeing a prior
belief
as blue,
uh, a likelihood is red, and then a
posterior is green, I think. What we're
looking at here is we're looking at
three posterior beliefs. So, we're
looking at three different
iteration or three different processes
by which Bayesian inference has happened
already, okay?
Uh and specifically for for three
different settings about what the real
world is in fact like.
So, over here, you know, the real
world's the the real
um
uh food size is two in this example.
And we can see that where this is the
case, the modeling assumption leads to a
posterior belief which puts most of the
probability mass around an incorrect
value, okay? So, this belief here, this
is wrong. This is I have I have done I
have observed the light intensity, and I
have updated my belief, and because my
model is wrong, my updated belief is
wrong, okay?
Now, in this state of the world over
here where the the hidden hidden food
size is 2.5, slightly bigger than two,
we can see that yes, we're still wrong,
but we're not quite as wrong, okay?
We're getting sort of better.
Uh but then if we make if the if the
food size if the real food size is is
bigger, you know, let's say 3.5, we see
that we're actually significantly wrong
again
uh in in in our updated belief, okay?
So, what the the the I'll I'll I'll stop
talking in a second and just get some
some questions after this, but the
important
thing that is being demonstrated here is
that
yes, our model can be wrong, our
assumptions about how the generative
process gives rise to observations can
be incorrect, but for some values of the
for some regions of the real world, it
can actually be okay. It can sort of
serve as a a rough and ready estimate.
So, and this is usually the case that
we're going to be in. Most of the models
that we make most of the time are wrong,
inverted commas, in the sense that they
do not exactly recapitulate the the
state of the world or the generative
process. They are instead
simplifications, and you you often hear
this term coarse graining, okay? So,
there's some very very detailed process
out there, there's very, you know,
sophisticated dynamics in the real world
and we're going to paint with a very
broad brush with our model, okay? We're
going to sort of assume that it's
simpler than it really is. This is a
very very common thing that will come up
again and again and again.
So, I wanted to make that point before
we before we moved on.
Was Were there any questions about that
or anything I have said so far? I I
heard someone before maybe with a
question.
Um yeah, I just that center figure
there, the Y axis is incorrectly
labeled.
Uh so, this one here or so, we've got
density credibility Ah, yes. Yes, you're
right. So, this this really should be a
a density here. Yeah.
Uh that's an errata. So,
this uh All right, that's that's a
fantastic thing to to note.
So, again, we can go down to the errata
here. I found a few errata in this
chapter actually. I did mention them in
the very first uh section of chapter
two.
I'll put this in here real quick. I will
come back and make it nicer. So,
location
figure
2. Uh
>> [snorts]
>> what's it's example 2.4.
Thank you. Thank you, Corvus, for that.
Figure 2.16 So, we're all set. Yeah,
there we go.
2.16
I'll go back and and make that nice.
Thank you for that.
And well, just while we're here, maybe
I'll note two other errata in this
chapter
cuz it's important.
Uh we have equation 2.14 and 2.17. We we
We covered this last time. There's very
minor
um
incorrect uh
you know, notation of of the parameters
of these distributions. It's not too
important. You can read what I've I've
put there as the errata, but technically
those are are incorrect as they are
stated.
So,
all right, Any any questions about kind
of where we left off
or anything about that exact example?
Going once, going twice.
All right.
Well, I think we can pick up then.
Do do. Let's go to Yeah, so
that really is chap That's kind of
section 2.1 and 2.2
dealt with. So, we're now going to
section 2.3, 2.4, and 2.5 are the
remaining sections. The 2.6 is just a
review or summary of the chapter in some
sense.
So, we've actually kind of already
covered the the very
you know, core idea about what chapter
chapter two is, and we're going to look
at some extensions of the idea now.
So, 2.3,
this I I should really explain to what
I've done here. So,
again, on the on each of the chapter
pages, I'm going to have a a picture
about what the what the actual chapter
is in terms of the content, what the
objectives of the session for the
chapter are, the chapter in a nutshell.
That's here.
Uh maybe sort of a key shift from or in
ideas or conceptual um level from
where we where chapter two is as
compared to chapter one,
a rough and ready content breakdown in
terms of the core, preview, deferred,
and optional ideas in the chapter. And
then I have this table down here,
chapter two map. So, this is for each
section. Uh so, let's go to section 2.2,
for example.
I try and recapitulate that same struct-
structure again within the section,
okay? So, we're going to see, you know,
what's the narrative role of this
section, what's the core idea in this
section, and so on, okay? Was there
conceptual shift shift from another
section,
and are there preview ideas?
So, that's where you where you can find
this material. Now, I think that's sort
of um
it a bit nicer than having it all on one
page at the same time. It can get a bit
messy.
So, as I said, we've just done 2.2.
We now We're now at 2.3.
So, what is 2.3? Well, really it's
exactly the same story that we've looked
at except now we're going to perform the
same inference procedure with multiple
observations. We're going to do not just
a single observation of the light
intensity, but we're going to have
multiple of them, okay? So, and it's
exactly the same mechanics, the same
mathematics that we've seen, but just
with multiple observations now.
So, let me get myself [clears throat]
grounded in
where the figures are that we would like
to see.
Yes, okay.
And the core equation, let me go there.
Well, yeah, let's let's
So, think about the central question is
like, how do we change our beliefs as
additional evidence accumulates from
multiple samples, multiple observations
of the hidden state, okay? So, we we
could update our belief just once and be
done with it, or we could continue to
update our belief with each successive
observation that we make.
That's the core
idea in this chapter. I don't want to
Maybe it will be useful, but I don't
think it will be too useful to go
through these points live in the
session. I think they're they're they're
useful orienting points, especially for
people who don't have the book between
sessions. I think we should really look
at figures and equations in in these
sessions.
Unless of course people feel
anything to the contrary.
So, what does this actually
couch out in? So,
equation 2.20, this is kind of the
central
equation in in this section, I think.
This is expressing mathematically what
we're going to be doing, okay? Now,
there's some nice figures which
communicate this in a nicer manner than
the the raw mathematics, but the idea
is, look, we we're using Y as our
notation for observations. We're going
to take in a bunch of observations, Y,
you know, the first observation, Y zero,
Y one, two, three, all the way up to N
for some number of observations.
Uh and we're going to try and update our
belief about what X is given a whole
bunch of observations.
There's a very, very, very crucial
assumption that's
is the reason why we can make this
the way that we're going to update our
beliefs. So, what what is what is it
saying here? This is saying that the
probability
that's
we we have certain observations given a
hidden state is given by the probability
of all of the individual
uh
observations given a hidden state
multiplied together.
And this is called an independent and
identically distributed assumption,
okay? So,
this is an assumption. It It may not
hold, but we make this assumption all
over the place. Largely because it makes
things easier for us.
Um but, I did want to note that this is
an assumption that we're making and it
doesn't hold generally or that there
might be
certain certain kinds of problems by
which you don't want to make this
assumption, okay? So, we shouldn't
assume that this is a general thing that
we can just do all the time and it's
always going to work, okay?
Now, that's not notated in our model,
okay? Because our model is is really
still
2.19, something that looks like this.
Um but, nevertheless, it is part of our
assumptions about what we will be
modeling, so.
The figure that that corresponds to this
is quite nice. I go to two.
It's very helpful. It's a bit more
helpful than looking at the raw
equations.
Uh really is 2.21.
So, 2.21, here we go.
Now, 2.21.
2.17, sorry, my mistake.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, so
this as I say this is just a visual
representation as to that equation that
I just showed you.
The idea is
where what what have what what is one of
the well the big assumption that we made
in this chapter
is that we want to be able to do
Bayesian inference and we can't do it in
the general case because we saw that
marginalization was a big problem.
So dividing by the
well that term in the bottom of of
Bayes' rule.
So in order to get around that in this
chapter we've assumed that we're going
to be able to chop up the probability
distributions at issue into a whole
bunch of you know small little points.
So we're going we're going to chop up
everything into 500
little discrete points and this this is
called grid approximation.
And then what we can do is we can
actually do this marginalization
procedure
by performing
products
well 500 times and then that that works
out quite nicely.
So
I don't know if
it might be worthwhile to go back over
that cuz that's quite a
important idea but the the relevance
that it has for this
figure here is that
each and every one of the observations
that we get in
this is going to be what's called a
vector
or rather the probability the likelihood
right associated with
this observation given a hidden state
is going to be a vector of 500 numbers
because we're we're discretizing
that will tell you how credible a given
hidden state is
with the with that observation. So
actually a better a better thing to look
at is I think it's figure 2.19.
Or 2.18, here we go.
So this is visually what
what's happening. We have these in These
are likelihood distributions.
They tell us how likely a given food
size is
based upon an observation that's coming
in.
Okay? And we've done this for 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 times. So, we we've taken nine
observations, and we have nine
likelihoods. Each one of these is really
It does It's not shown here, but it's
really been chopped up into 500, you
know, fine points, okay? That's how
we're approximating these distributions
in this chapter.
Now, that's nice. So, we want to update
our belief about the hidden states to
get our posterior belief about what the
the hidden state really is, what the
food size really is, given these nine
observations that we've made now.
And the way that we're going to do that
is we're basically going to multiply all
of these distributions together from top
to bottom.
That's essentially the the qualitatively
the procedure that's happening, and that
is what is shown in
this figure 2.17.
So, we we In this case, we have nine and
big N is equal to nine. We multiply them
all together to get this
uh
joint likelihood here, okay? This is the
This is equation 2.20. That results in
just one
2.19
just one likelihood over all of the
observations that we've made, okay?
This is that the result of that big old
multiplication that we just saw.
And indeed in the in the book, you know,
he says, "Look, assume for this example
that the hidden uh
So, to visualize this process, what what
this process looks like, we will use a
single example where X star, the hidden
state, the real hidden state, the food
size, is two, okay?"
So, what this is saying is now, okay,
we've taken in nine observations of
light intensities. We're We're And we
have a a likelihood distribution now.
What does that mean?
What that means is this distribution is
telling us how credible or how likely
a given food size is
to have generated the observations that
we saw. So, what did we see? We saw nine
observations, okay?
This is telling us that look, you know,
food size of two, it's got a pretty good
chance of having given us the
observations that we saw, okay? Food
size of four has a very very almost no
chance of
generating the observations that we did
see, okay? That's what this is saying
uh qualitatively, okay? This is not our
posterior belief
yet. It will become the posterior belief
once we've sort of done Bayes' rule.
And we can do Bayes' rule because we've
made an assumption. We we're using grid
approximation. We're we're chopping up
everything into 500 uh you know, fine
points here.
Yeah, just on that point, the Y axis
once again, I believe, should be called
credibility instead of the
Yes, yes. So, there's the this is an
important subtle point here. This thing
that we're looking at, um
it's called a likelihood distribution.
Really, it's a likelihood function,
okay? A probability distribution has to
have a very special property, which is
that if you look at the area under the
curve, it has to equal one, all right?
That's not actually the case necessarily
for a likelihood, okay? Usually, it's
it's not going to equal one, so it's not
a proper probability distribution.
And for that reason, we
the word density is is reserved for
probability distributions in in
probability theory. So, this Again, this
is yet another errata. Thank you, uh
Kobus. This should really be called uh a
credibility, okay? He does He does talk
about this in the book, and he he
mentions it it correctly in the main
text.
Um I don't know if it's worthwhile to
find that just now,
but that is that is an important point.
So, the thing is, like the the way that
we Well, let me
I'll
I'll put it in later. I'll put it in
later. But thank you, Curtis, for that.
So, we need to we need to somehow turn
this into a probability. That's the
idea.
And the way that we do that is by
dividing by the the term on the bottom
of Bayes' rule, the marginal
evidence. Okay, that is what actually
turns this into a probability
with our prior belief as well. So,
uh
I don't know if it's
I I've shown that before. I don't know
if it's worth showing again.
Mhm, come here.
Yes. All right. So, yeah, well, let's
look at
Let's let's make that explicit, I think.
2.22, equation 2.22 is where we want to
go.
Do you put your questions in the chat as
well? I am monitoring that.
It's a bit hard. Maybe Andrew, it'd be
good if you could have a look at the
chat while I'm
talking away here.
We're sure. Uh
There's nothing to mention now. I had a
look. Okay.
All right. So,
this equation here, 2.22, this is really
expressing everything I just said
mathematically. So, what is this? This
is Bayes' rule, except now we have
multiple observations. Okay?
And we're using our assumption about the
fact that the observations are all
independent of one another.
They're independent and identically
distributed.
Uh and that allows us to say, "Look, all
right. Well, let's say I take in nine
observations, Y I from zero to to nine.
Let's pretend N is N is nine."
Uh well, then my my posterior belief
about
um
the hidden food size, uh you know, given
that I've observed nine observations of
light intensity,
is equal to the multiplication
Another word for multiplication is
product. So, the product of all of the
constituent likelihoods for, you know,
I1 given X, I2 given X all the way to I9
multiplied by my prior belief about the
hidden food sizes divided by the
marginal evidence for each each
observation.
That is then our prior belief and
dividing by
this marginal here is what turns the
numerator or rather the
well, it's it's what makes sure that the
whole expression is a probability. It's
number between zero and one.
So that's kind of the culmination of of
2.3 although there is an important
notational convention to to clear up
after this. So
Do you have any comments there Andrew or
anything you think I've missed so far?
No, I I think this is I think this is
quite good.
I think that you're you're kind of
highlighting the core points because of
course there's a lot regarding handling
of of probability distributions and just
general knowledge of probability theory
that go into these sorts of sections. So
I think it's worth just dealing with any
kind of you know potential ambiguity and
it's worthwhile for those who are
interested in the underlying kind of
aspects of probability theory to perhaps
follow up or there's plenty of resources
in the textbook. In the meantime, I'm
just following up with some more details
on credibility in the in the chat and we
can probably put those as a question in
the coda.
And as as Kobus has found some some of
those erasa around the the linkage
between credibility and probability,
we'll go back and and and put those in
the erasa because it is important to
distinguish those two things.
What I'm looking at here on the screen
again, this is just hopefully yet
another intuition pump but I suppose
this is figure
2.20.
This is a visual depiction. We saw this
before in well, in the first session.
This is a what's known as a Bayesian
network. It's a way of visualizing a
model. Okay.
So this is this is a visual picture
about the relationship between the
the variables in our model, okay? I
don't want to go back over that again
cuz we we did that in the previous
session. We can later if if if need be.
But the crucial distinction here is that
we now have this thing called a plate,
okay? This is this is called plate
notation. Where it's exactly the same
model that we had before except we're
going to repeat the observations that we
have for, you know, we did it for nine
observations, but we can do it for n
times. So, any any time there is this
boxed portion or this plate portion in
in a in a a Bayesian network where
you've got this I going from zero to n,
this is saying that this component is
repeated n times. So, really what this
looks like is you can sort of imagine
that X is like the the center of a
flower and all these Y eyes are like the
petals. So, if there's if there's nine Y
eyes, there'd be nine petals, right?
It'd be like a star, basically.
Um that's that's what that's saying.
It's just a convenient way to
communicate the information that, you
know, this Y I think is being repeated.
That's that's what that means. So,
hopefully that's maybe yet another sort
of
um way of especializing what what the
model is in this case.
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
Mhm.
Yes, so the the last
the last thing really, I mean, there's
one more example,
but I do want to look at 2.23 and 2.24,
those equations. These are important
now.
I'm trying as much as I can to not show
you equations when I don't have to.
>> [laughter]
>> I think that's always nice in terms of
intuition.
But it it it this does bear there is
some
this is important enough to to mention.
So, 2.23,
you're looking at the equation 2.23 now.
This is
what's very very when we're dealing with
the the likelihood. Okay, then we saw
that in 2.22.
I'll just show you that again so that
you know what I'm talking about.
So, this is the likelihood here. Okay,
this is just part of Bayes' rule,
likelihood, prior, marginal, posterior.
Okay, we're talking about the
likelihood.
When we when we're dealing with the
likelihood and when we're doing
computational operations that involve
the likelihood,
usually it's it's much nicer to
take the logarithm of the likelihood.
Okay, this is effectively a
transformation. I'm not going to I can't
explain fully what logarithms here are
just now, although I will say in the
appendix there are he does talk about
logarithms quite nicely.
It's effectively a transformation that
makes the
that has
that plays well with computer
the way that computers process numbers.
So, this is just a sort of nice
transformation that we often do to the
likelihood to make things easier to
compute.
So,
that's as much as I'll say just now
other than to say that when we do this,
all right, we've taken the we've taken a
bunch we've taken nine observations we
could take n
and we've multiplied the individual
likelihoods together and that gives us
our sort of joint likelihood, right?
So, that's called a product when you
multiply things together.
That's this thing in here.
When you take the log of a product,
something very magical happens. You end
up getting the sum of the log of the
things. So,
this is
it takes a little while to to get used
to this, but what this logarithm
transformation does is it turns the
multiplication of things into adding the
log of those things.
Which is a very very nice thing if
you're dealing with computational
problems on on computers. So,
almost always when we're dealing with
the likelihood, we're actually going to
implement the log likelihood, and it's
just it's just the logarithm of our
likelihood term, okay?
That's very very common.
So,
maybe a nicer way to show this is, and
this is immediately
you know, 2. Equation 2.24 immediately
follows on,
if we look at the entire numerator of
Bayes' rule, okay? So, we've got our
product of likelihood terms times our
prior belief. What it Where is that
from? That is just from Bayes' rule.
It's just from here.
Okay, so that's the numerator of Bayes'
rule. If we look at that now,
uh 2.24, and we take the log we take the
logarithm of that,
we have a product of independent
likelihoods multiplied by a prior
belief.
Well, that's just a product times
something else, okay? It's just a big a
giant product, really.
So, if I take the log of a product, I
get the
sum of the logs. So, that means that
this whole thing gets turned into the
sum of the independent log likelihoods
plus the log of the prior, okay?
Now, this is very much what we're going
to be working with most of the time.
Andrew, please.
I'm probably just re- reiterating some
aspects of what you said, Fraser, but
yes, I want to I also want to emphasize
this this log transformation. We're kind
of transforming things into a log scale
and its many kind of special properties
that allow us to do many different kinds
of things. So, again, as Fraser has
said, we'll be seeing this sort of
operation being done very frequently
going forward. It'll feature in
computing free energy and and expected
free energy and all the like in later
chapters. And then here again, we can
see like by being able to kind of change
what would have been
uh you know, a multiplication or product
operation into a much simpler, more
tractable summation. Uh these are the
kinds of properties of logarithms that
allow us to do different kinds of sort
of variational message
uh excuse me, variational uh inference
methods. And then later in this chapter,
we see that we can replace entire
uh you know, distributions such as a
normal distribution. Um we we can have
it in a sort of log form, and that
allows us to do things like find log
likelihood. Anyway, I'm skipping ahead
and so I'll just stop there.
Very much preview preview material,
yeah.
Well,
we we we want to cover 2.4 now, the
generative model. Uh there's so there's
very important things to talk about in
there. And then really the last part of
the chapter I that I think is relevant
is uh
section 2.5. 2.6 is um
uh really review, where we talk about
some non-Bayesian two non-Bayesian ways
of doing things, and then we also
motivate um iterative solutions. Before
I do that, um there's two things I'd
like to do. I'd like to just ask if
there's any questions right now about
anything I've said or anything unclear.
Um and then Andrew, I would like to
raise the uh so Andrew's put together a
very nice initial
um
computational uh
thing that you can play with to to
visualize the relationships that we've
been talking about in chapter two for
all of the examples. So, but just
quickly, are there are there any
questions right now that would be
worthwhile to look at?
Credibility on page 28.
If not,
um
I'd like to maybe then talk about your
example, Andrew. So,
let me I'll just grab it real quick.
I'll stop sharing.
Because this is very I I I like this a
lot because it gives you the intuition
that you need uh to be able to play with
these things. Here we go.
Change this around. Sorry, I thought I
had this all nice before and clearly I
didn't.
It's quite all right. I'm happy to
Yeah, I put a link to it in
under the code subpage in the coda.
I've got it now. Here we go. This is
So, share that. Well, it's probably good
to show in the coda. Why did you put it
in the coda, by the way? Uh Yeah. Yeah,
you'll just find it near the top of the
code subpage. It's a bit below. There
you are. Here we go. Coda page there.
And GitHub, yep. And so, at the very
top, you can see Daniel's previous
2-minute video that gives a nice short
kind of explanation of how we're setting
up the repo for the fundamentals
textbook. And then immediately under
that, you'll see this chapter in browser
demos. I just want to clarify like these
are all done in
a service called Google Colab. It is
entirely free, at least as far as
you know, the the amount of compute you
need in order to run these demos. They
run entirely in your browser. There's no
installation.
You don't have to be a programmer. There
are two instructions. You simply run all
at the top and it will do everything for
you. And then after that, there's
interactivity. So, yeah, if you don't
mind clicking, it should be a relatively
short demo because we're just sort of in
piecemeal
sort of adding more topics to this
notebook. So, yeah, this is a live demo
and that means that something will
almost essentially
like go wrong. So,
Yeah. Yeah, so what we're what what's
helpful is that um
this demo is essentially pulling
directly from the institute repo. And
so, that means that whenever we make
updates and things like that, of course,
we'll have to be careful not to not to
break the demos as well, but we'll be
mindful about that. But in any case, it
means that as soon as we add something
to the repo, it's relatively easy to
just demonstrate it within these
notebooks. and then um I'm adding
additional material. So, yeah, um I'll
just start from the top. Do you mind
just clicking run all?
Um Yep. Uh
run all. So, this here this These are
For those who don't know, this is like a
a notebook setup where there are cells
and you can run individual cells of code
and whatever. But, we'll just run all
for now. So, warning this was not
authored by Google. Yes, I'm aware. Run
all. So, that's You see this little spin
wheel here. This is running this cell of
code. It's running all the cells of
code, actually.
Uh when I did this before, it took about
a minute or so.
Uh
so, yeah. I mean, the way that Andrew
has set this up is to try and make
things very easy for you is he's
actually cloning the entire
um repo here. So, there's a bit of
setup. There we go.
Okay. Yeah, it takes
relatively little time. So, that's all
set. And then if you were to just scroll
down, and you'll see here some
instructions and they say what the
parameters are. The main thing though is
that this first There are only three
sections total right now. This first one
is for hidden state estimation. And so,
yeah. Uh you saw that Fraser didn't have
to click on anything else. He simply
scrolled down, right? So, you would
scroll to here and then you can see
these little sliders for adjusting Y,
which is your sample. Um M of X, which
is the as we see in chapter two, that is
the mean on the prior that the our um
model has. Right now, this is just a
linear regression uh the linear
regression example. Um but it only does
>> now. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And so, um what you
can do is you can simply adjust the
sliders and then you'll actually see the
impact um that these the changes you
make in the parameters and the noise of
the observations, of the value of the
observation itself, um
how that ends up changing the resulting
priors and likelihoods and and
posteriors. Um I think it's very useful
because you can kind of see and play
around with it, see what um sort of uh
get a a better intuitive sense of how
these parameters like directly modify or
change these distributions.
Um, and we can see the impact of things
like noise,
or, yeah, exactly. So, if we reduce our,
um, standard deviation, or reduce our
noise on the observation, you notice
that these distributions become much
more, uh, like,
sort of spike-like, right? They become
much more narrow and concentrated
because of the reduced amount of
variance. Uh, whereas, which is why we
can call, we frequently call the the
variance the inverse precision. So, if
you look at it sort of the other way
around, like if you have very low
variance, then you have very high
precision, and that makes these
distributions much more precise, we'll
call them, as opposed to spread out. So,
um,
it's a little bit longer than I need to
go on that particular example. So, the
the the next two sections, um,
yeah, if you wouldn't mind, uh,
scrolling a bit, Fraser. The, yeah, this
is just additional information. I'm
trying not to overflood these notebooks,
but they do have these little toggle
switches on the left-hand side that, uh,
make it much more convenient. You can
just sort of collapse anything that, um,
you're not currently looking at. It
makes the
>> yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so I can do that. No, no, no,
yeah, yeah. Just if it's useful. Yeah,
there you go. Uh, so, next, the next two
examples are both examples, uh,
demonstrating gradient descent, which
you see near the end, almost the very
end of chapter two, but it's a very
important sort of concept because for
those who
>> to cover that, yeah. We will, so. Yeah,
yeah, we'll we'll hear hear phrases of,
um, minimizing, or doing some sort of
gradient descent on a negative free
energy,
um, those sorts of things later. So,
kind of wrapping your head a bit around
gradient descent is very helpful. And as
we saw in chapter two, um, it's, uh,
there are two different methods that
get, um,
kind of employed in the gradient descent
examples. So, the first one matches the
MLE, or maximum likelihood estimation
Um,
application of gradient descent and then
the second one simply shows the map or
maximum a posteriori
method, right?
Um
Oh, that's quite interesting. So, it may
have to change the rendering on that
whenever you
Yeah, kind of force it to a very high
number of samples, but you can see that
what we're doing is we're iteratively
collecting
samples like observations and then we
have some kind of prior. We have some
kind of learning rate which I will note
I'm fixing the the learning rate
display. It still works correctly, but
you can see it looks as if it's always
zero
in the in the display there. Um
Uh but in any case, we know that the
learning rate kind of amplifies the
impact of the update to be made, right?
We kind of take larger or shorter step
sizes based on that. So, it's also
frequently called a step size.
So, similarly, you have the same thing
for maximum
um
a posteriori estimation except of course
we see that we also have prior beliefs
involved in our model, right? That's
what kind of distinguishes the two. MLE
maximum likelihood estimation it only
uses a likelihood to make that
estimation.
The map estimation uses both a prior and
a likelihood. So, it gets us sort of
that much closer to to the appearance of
a kind of Bayesian framework. Um
And yeah, that's I think that generally
covers the demo and so in future what
I'd love to do is just include more
interactivity and kind of make these
easier to navigate. Um but that said, it
is
you know, it's a sort of a
a non-trivial amount of work to kind of
develop these and so with that in mind
for anyone who has anything in
particular in mind that they would like
to see in these demos or there's a
particular concept or method that they
would like to see a code application or
at least some way of interacting with it
to kind of play around with it and see
if there's an
a way that they can sort of practice
their own active inference to sort of
learn how these things work, then uh
please reach out to us at uh blanket at
at activeinference.institute
or you can just email me um personally
or or leave some kind of note in the uh
in the coda. And uh Oh, great. Yeah, it
would uh we'd love to build these out
going forward. It's just obviously as a
as a team of three with our own sort of
respective lives, we do have to
prioritize sort of what we develop next.
So, we're
we would most likely not be able to
benefit really really powerful thing
being you know, being able to move those
those sliders around seeing real time
how they change things cuz you know,
it's one thing to see it on the page
statically. That's um I think that's a
really powerful uh you know, way of way
of functioning. So, thank you very much
Andrew. I'm going to hopefully confer
with you to to make those very you know,
better and everything. So,
Excellent. All right. Well, we have not
a lot of time left. I want to get to uh
gradient descent, maximum likelihood,
maximum a posteriori,
uh but but before we do uh and I showed
this before, this is so, we're now in
sort of um section 2.4 inside the
generative model where he takes a bit of
a step back and tries to to talk about
well, what is the structure of the
generative model itself and and how can
we kind of visualize things? What's
going on?
I think the central uh
uh figure here really is figure 2.4.
This is very very instructive in a lot
of ways.
Um And the the main problem we're
looking at again sort of as always,
well, not quite as always, uh equation
2.25, come here.
So,
is this issue of marginalization. So,
our generative model is a joint
probability distribution between
observations and hidden states.
Observations Y and states X. So, that is
what our generative model is. It's on
the burden of us to make it to specify
what this is, okay? And we can we we
know that mathematically that we can
factorize this as a likelihood and a
prior, very nice.
But to get the marginal distribution of
observations, we have to add or sum
across every possible hidden state
in our um our generative model, and that
will give us our marginal distribution.
So, if I go back to the
uh the figure 2.24,
where is that here?
Do do do.
I have it. There we go, yeah.
We're looking at So, what we're what
we're seeing here is uh we have a
two-dimensional generative model, light
intensity observations, food size hidden
states, and this is our uh normal um
distribution here.
Our posterior belief, so our belief
about what the hidden food size is after
having observed the light intensity, is
a green slice across light intensity
this way. So, this this green slice
here, we have a light intensity of 300.
By the way, he's just multiplied all the
numbers by by 100 to make them easier to
see, okay?
Uh so, we you know, we observe a light
intensity of 300, slice our generative
model this way, this green thing is the
the the posterior belief that we would
have about what the food size was that
generated uh that light intensity. We
can see it's probably around about
uh
250 or so, okay?
So, that's that's how we get posterior
beliefs from our generative model. We
sort of slice them in that direction.
How do we get marginal beliefs? Well,
this red thing is a marginal belief
about the food size given every possible
uh observ- observation that we could
make. So, not a single one, but every
single one of them. And it's kind of
like the projection of the generative
model as a casting a shadow onto the
food size axis. The one that actually
really matters for us in Bayesian
inference is the marginal that lives
over here, over light intensities. So,
what's the light intensity you could get
for any food size whatsoever, that would
be a distribution that lives over here.
So,
as I say, that this is kind of like this
the the linchpin uh figure in in almost
all of chapter two. I think it's very
important. It communicates a lot of
central ideas.
Uh and and yes, this this is a a proper
density here. Uh that's that's labeled
correctly.
Okay.
Now, from here, we actually sort of
change tack a little bit
and we move into the
two non-Bayesian ways of doing things,
okay? So, then this is this maximum
likelihood estimation and maximum a
posteriori estimation. Interesting, you
know, funny words. So, I just want to
quickly go down to the equations cuz I I
I want to briefly show them.
Uh so, equation 2.26,
this is not anything crazy. He's just
going to name this this this triangle
equals means I'm just going to make
define the thing on the right-hand side
to be the thing on the left-hand side.
So, we're going to call the likelihood
distribution here
uh this L X, this script L X. We're just
going to name uh you know, L X to be
this rather than having to write the
full likelihood every time.
And when we're doing maximum likelihood
estimation,
we're trying to find the value of the
likelihood that
well, we're trying to find the value of
the hidden state
that when you put it into the
likelihood,
gives you the maximum likelihood.
So, mathematically, how do you say that?
Well, we have our likelihood over here.
The things that go inside the likelihood
are called arguments. So, X is the only
argument.
And the way we say what's the value of X
that gives me the maximum likelihood is
argmax. So, not too important you you
find that out, but that's what this
means. So, argmax over X of L X is
saying, "What's the value of X that when
I put it into the likelihood gives me
the biggest like, you know, value for
the likelihood?
That's the problem.
So, and the value of X that gives you
the maximum likelihood is called the
maximum likelihood estimate of X, XMLE.
That's what that is.
So, and as I again, once
once again, we're usually in the
business of dealing with log
likelihoods. So, equation 2.29,
this is exactly the same thing you just
saw, arc max of X across the sum of all
of the log of the likelihoods.
That's actually going to be what we use
most of the time, okay?
The only difference here is that we've
taken the log of this quantity. And
we're going to denote that with a script
L, a lowercase script L. Okay, that's
really just notational convention.
That's not really anything substantive.
So, now we actually move in in 2.5.1 to
MLE and MAP estimation. So, there's two
ways you can do maximum likelihood
estimation and maximum a posteriori
estimation.
You can do it kind of exactly.
Now, I don't have a nice visualization
of the process here, but I do in my
notes
uh 2.5.
This is very important, 2.5.1.
So, these are my my notes here.
Uh do go and have a look over these
after we're done. I know we've got only
6 minutes left, so I'm going to have to
be very qualitative.
Preview. Oh, I'm not going to be able to
find it in time, am I? Uh
yes, here we go. The inference recipe.
So, this is what I want to summarize.
There's five steps that he gives you for
being able to do maximum likelihood and
maximum a posteriori
inference in an exact way, okay? And you
follow these steps here. I'm not going
to I I don't have time to go through
them, but if you do that for in our
particular case, you get So, let's go to
equations. Equation 2.3 is what I want.
Uh
2.30.
Here we go.
If you do it exactly, the maximum
likelihood estimate for X that you get
for us is the av- the average over the
observations
minus the parameters in our model or
minus the parameter beta divided by beta
one. This gives you the the exact
version of the maximum likelihood
estimate for X. And you could use that,
okay?
But
we could equally well
well
So, that's how we do maximum likelihood
in in the exact case. We could also do
uh the gradient descent or iterative
solution.
Which I think we might have to cover
potentially at the beginning of the next
session because what I want to contrast
this with is the maximum a posteriori
estimate.
>> [laughter]
>> So, the MAP estimate, all right?
What is that? It's actually exactly the
same thing
that we do for MLE
except now, I really want equation 2.32.
That's what I mean. Um, there's not a
good figure, unfortunately, that I can
show you.
This is exactly the same thing except
now we add in a prior. Okay?
Or rather we multiply a prior and then
when we take the log we get the
addition. And this is
precisely exactly the same thing as MLE.
The only difference is that we have this
prior belief now. Okay?
Now, when we take this is the I think
the most important thing, this unify
I'll I'll I'll stop talking after this.
When we want to find the maximum
likelihood either through
you know, iterative solution or through
exact infra- uh
exact analytical procedures
So, there's there's two ways we can do
it. We can either do it by gradient
descent or we can do it through an
analytical procedure. So, 2.25 is what I
want. Here we go.
Let's pretend that this is the
likelihood distribution.
Well
it's not actually the likelihood
distribution. In machine learning most
of the time we want to minimize things.
So, we actually just multiply it by -1
and we find the negative log likelihood.
So, what we're finding here is the
negative log likelihood,
or rather the value for X that gives us
the most negative log likelihood. What
is that? Well, it looks like it's
probably about 2.5 or so.
That's great. Here's the key thing
though. That's just a number. That's
just a point estimate. We have thrown
away all uncertainty.
With our Bayesian methods, with our
approximation to Bayes' rule, we're able
to sort of keep track of uncertainty.
With these other with these two other
ways of doing a sort of non-Bayesian
flavor of inference, we don't have
uncertainty anymore. We just have a
point estimate. We have a single number.
That's the key the key thing to take
away, I would say. So, we we haven't
really spent
any time here talking about MLE and MAP
in terms of how they cash out
computationally either as gradient
descent or in the analytical case. I
think we'll have to stop it there cuz
we're sort of at time.
Uh and then 2.6 is really just summary
and conclusions about what we've done,
the assumptions we've made in this
chapter, and where we're going in
chapter three.
Uh so, chapter three is very much about
doing the same thing again that we did
in chapter two, except now we're going
to have to deal with
uh this issue of learning the
parameters. So, what are the good
parameters that we're going to to to
plug in to our models. You can see that
in my my summary.
So, I'd like to hand it over to
just general questions. I know we're
sort of at time.
Uh I will stop sharing my screen.
And I will I'll stop the recording in
about two minutes, but is there anything
that anyone would like to ask on the
recording uh
before we stop the recording.
I can I mean, we're we've got 1 minute 1
minute technically, but and then I'll
stop the recording and then anyone who
wants to talk afterwards they can.
Andrew?
May not be the best time, but for the
sake of the recording, um yeah, it
I I would support going into gradient
descent um next week, But then that
said,
uh yeah, it's it's worthwhile to just
note the the importance of this sort of
iterative variational aspect of gradient
descent, right? Where we're able to make
many sort of micro updates over time,
and we're not doing anything
particularly clever at that point. We're
just using many of the sort of aspects
of the mathematics prior to those sec-
prior to the gradient descent section.
So, chapter two kind of prepares you for
the gradient descent at the end of
chapter two.
And what we're doing is we're still
taking our distributions, we're putting
them into a log forms. Now we're looking
at sort of log likelihoods. And then
this is just a conventional thing, but
we then make those negative. And so now
instead of it becoming a maximization
problem, it becomes a minimiz- minimums
minimization problem. Thank you.
And thus the name gradient descent
rather than ascent. And so we're just
trying to sort of minimize that. So, we
just recompute that negative log
likelihood.
And then we can kind of scale it using
this this learning rate, right? How big
each step is. So, you can imagine kind
of kind of descending these these peaks
and valleys in a in a large landscape.
And so whenever we sort of reach a sort
of minimum point, we say that's where
we've sort of converged. And then the
final issue, of course, for those who
already familiar with these things know
is that we can end up reaching what some
might call a saddle point or what others
might call a local minimum. Which is
where we don't actually know if we've
kind of reached the global
end-all be-all minimum
given that we're just proceeding
iteratively, right? So, this is a sort
of limitation to gradient descent
methods. We're not guaranteed to sort of
find the lowest trough out of all of the
the the landscape. But we can find
something that's sort of potentially
close to us. So, and yeah, you
pulled up a great example.
>> usually looking at something yeah, very
crazy, very you know, this is just even
this is only two dimensions. This is
really quite trivial. Yeah, this is just
a quadratic function. There's a we can
just see what the minimum is. But in
most of our problems, they're going to
be very very very high dimensional.
There's going to be all kinds of peaks
and troughs and it's going to be very
unclear where the minimum should be. So,
yeah, that's a very good point for sure.
All right.
Okay, I'm going to stop the recording
just now and then anyone who wants to
ask any live question can.
Let me stop that. Stop that.
All righty. And I think yes, we'll we'll
start off next week with just a quick
go through of gradient descent cuz we
didn't really get to it here in time and
then we'll look at chapter three, which
is an extension of chapter two where
we're looking at parameter inference or
rather learning now. So, it's very very
exciting chapter. So, thank you
everyone. I'll stop the recording and
here.
All right, goodbye those who are
watching on YouTube.